today's topic power dynamics this is a
topic that came up
and i i had so many thoughts on it so i
was like let me
think it over pirate dynamics is the
idea that especially within
relationships that there
are sometimes specific partners within
dynamic who may have more power than the
other
and at some point this imbalance can be
so great that the relationship can
almost seem predatory
fair i said this in the last video but
i'll say it again
unless this person is your boss and even
then
unless this person is your correctional
officer is the police officer charging
you
the lawyer presiding over you like
unless it's one of those situations
i genuinely don't care about who you
choose to date
unless this person has legal
guardianship over you or you're i
don't care this idea that oh there's a
power imbalance have you guys never had
a deep-seated crush for somebody
do you not remember being a young person
and you had a huge question that person
could have suited
even when i was 18 20 like when i had a
huge crush on somebody
did they have this huge power dynamic
where they were being predatory
are ig thoughts who are fleecing their
sims
being predatory by using their beauty
and their power over other people
do you know how many very attractive
people i know of or i've heard of who
are garnering all kinds of favors in
life because they have some kind of hold
over others
what about rich people who are seemingly
able to
garner affection from most of the people
that they'd like just because they have
tremendous amounts of money
are they being predatory too how far do
we want to take it
oh the problem is when you're soliciting
news why is that the main issue
if you want to be somebody who sends
pictures of yourself to somebody else
because you admire them
that's on you have people turn into such
babies that we have to protect them from
everything
you don't have enough agency to look at
someone you admire
and be like no listen i like a lot of
people
if they came in my dms today and like i
want to see you i'm not doing it
and if you would that's your
problem and if you guys are going to go
around canceling people
who want to sleep with their fans it's
such a dumb way to go about it because
you're you're putting
you're putting the the spotlight on one
thing as if it's not a society-wide
reality for all different walks of life
i can't understand the idea
that someone's grown enough to again
join the military
joint enough to take out hundreds of
thousands of loans open a business
do whatever they want but they can't
decide whether or not they want to take
a picture of themselves and sell it to
the person
now this has come from somebody that one
doesn't like newt and i tell people
don't ever send them to me this comes
from somebody who
generally someone says they're a huge
fan i'm not i don't like it but i
can't just from an ethical standpoint
understand
why that would be a bronton if people
want to be groupies
let them be groupies why are you
a third party coming in and be like
that's predatory mind your
business was that pretty calm
not towards the end well i'm losing it
bro
what i have to say about this is i have
a motorcycle
i have a very powerful motorcycle it's a
legend of a motorcycle
it's pretty goddamn fast i mean power
i most of my friends have cars that
don't have the amount of horsepowers
that my motorcycle have now
me with all that power
knowing that my motorcycle it's a
hayabusa
can go 300 kilometers
per hour divide by 1.6 to have
the miles per hour all right this is the
world america
i don't have to run it all the time i
don't have to
people are astonished that i don't have
more tickets than that
it's not people because someone has
power
that they're automatically gonna
understand how it could sound but it's
not
like it's not a reality of things even
engaging in a relationship
you could be in a relationship and you
think there's a power dynamic
it doesn't mean that the person is gonna
abuse from it
now if the person is acting because
the person is impressed by the power
that person has
the person is not doing anything you
know what i mean
i'm giving you another example there's a
lot of people that
that are saying that i'm intimidating
and you're intimidating
no no you little [ __ ]
are intimidated i haven't done [ __ ] to
you
i'm not even looking at you i'm on the
side of the room
you in a bit of a big room you don't
have to stand next to me
you walk in the room you feel
intimidated
i haven't done [ __ ] you want to give you
a different example
there are very attractive women who guys
go like you seduced me
no no you were seduced you were seduced
you saw her
and felt like she was making a signal to
you she was just standing there
looking good and that's it and sometimes
the bartender
is just polite she ain't trying to hook
up with you
you got seduce that's your thing
that's not her clown not her circus
that's on you boo boo
so it's not because you feel some type
of way because of the power of the
person the money the person has the
beauty the person has
that they are going to act on it
sometimes
it's you even if the person is
being proposed something and there's a
power dynamic
and the person says yes he is still not
abusing of his power
he's not you know everyone wants to be a
a crusader it's cringe everyone wants to
take
up a cause that they don't actually
really believe in or understand
they use words like grooming and oh my
god he's a pedobearer
it's like you guys don't even know the
definitions of the words you just miss
using because you saw it on tumblr or
twitter a couple times
it's cute and everything whenever it
swears like on fleek
or on deck or lit or trill
and then you use it and abuse it because
not even knowing exactly what it means
that's a little world a little word but
when it comes to
better words that has more baggage
and more implication in them it can
become it can become very dangerous
calling someone a groomer that is not
grooming that's not what it means
that word you're using that you're using
like that willy-nilly
it doesn't mean what you think it means
you know what i mean there are
consequences to that
lives are being ruined people act like
celebrities or these magical creatures
ruff i'm telling you there's a lot of
people who get whatever they want who
have nothing to do with celebrity status
whether they're super attractive look at
ig thoughts they got millions of
followers for just posting pictures
they could go into their dms and pick
anyone and they often do
and guess what there's nothing wrong
with it
do you do you if you want to fleece
those simps
go ahead i don't care but what i do have
an issue with
is how much work everybody wants all
these additional rights and
blah blah blah but nobody wants to have
any kinds of responsibility towards
their own well-being
they want to make it everyone else's
responsibility for them to be okay
yeah as if they have
no responsibility uh he was a celebrity
and i was just so enamored with him so
so that's your problem i don't know what
to tell you maybe you shouldn't bind to
celebrity culture that way
and if you can't stop yourself maybe
you'll have some soul-searching to do
because there's a lot of us who really
can we're not saying that you know
it doesn't happen but it's not
everything no no no they make it sound
like
you can't ever do this no that's what
i'm saying they don't like to be
accounted
for what they do they don't like to be
accountable yeah they don't like to be
you know what
you [ __ ] up or you engaged in that
behavior you fed that you
need counseling that counseling is not a
bad thing but
you there's some things that you need to
sort out
right there's some things that you have
to people don't like that
i'm just a little perfect bunny no
nobody is
but you have to work on yourself and
sometimes whenever you're like oh my god
it was so this and that is
impressionable and all this money
and all this power and all that it tells
more about yourself than
about a person but i'm not saying it's
all the cases of course
you know what it makes me think of it's
like when they used to have execution
squares
yeah you know when people just show up
and they don't even know who's being
executed but then all of a sudden
they're cheering
yeah they just people love it it's the
burning the witches all over again rough
it's set
so you know that's what i feel about
this this i think it's stupid uh
and those are my thoughts on it that's
all i got let us know what you guys
think in the comments below you're gonna
be the one who didn't exist so
you can start playing the beat right now
[Music]
um